House Republicans yesterday voted to
overturn two bills that had been passed
by the D.C Council that would allow
non-citizens to vote in local elections
and go even softer on criminals
and Congress lady Alexandria
ocasio-cortez she is not happy about it
in direct contradiction of their
quote-unquote conservative values of
small government and defending Freedom
have decided to expand the jurisdiction
of this body to meddle into the the
business of D.C residents the D.C city
council has the right to determine its
policies for D.C residents and if any
member of this body does not like that
they are feel they can feel free to
change their registration resign their
post and run for D.C City Council
now AOC says lots of things that are not
true but very often the false things
that she says are false because they are
exaggerations or selective
interpretations or imaginative
predictions in this case though what AOC
said is just perfectly precisely
easily demonstrably wrong the D.C city
council does not have the right to
determine the policies for D.C residents
Congress does have that right and that
right doesn't come from some obscure
section of the U.S code or some
little-known Court decision it is laid
out explicitly in the Constitution
Article 1 Section 8 quote the Congress
shall have the power to exercise
exclusive legislation in all cases
whatsoever over the Federal District of
Washington D.C now at first I figured
AOC was just being disingenuous
the more I listen to her rant though the
more convinced I became that she just
sincerely doesn't have any idea how the
Constitution established the government
of D.C
I understand that there may be
disagreements I understand that the that
that Republicans may not be happy with
what the D.C city council is doing but
when cities in Vermont pass the same
Provisions when San Francisco when nine
Maryland cities brought up this
provision did the Republican Party
Corral all of Congress and bring this
issue down to the floor for a vote no
they did not they are singling out the
residents of the District of Columbia
and expanding in the history of
disenfranchisement that goes all the way
back to the legacy of slavery and
they're bringing it right here to this
floor because why they don't have any
real bills to debate
no it's just because that's congress's
job
the Congress is not overruling laws in
Vermont and Maryland and in San
Francisco because that's not congress's
responsibility
it's just basic Civics the sort of thing
you're supposed to learn by the fifth
grade especially in a republic which
cannot endure if even the elected
representatives don't understand the
basic functions of the government I
don't usually go after AOC these days I
don't hit her so much anymore because I
feel it's played out I feel this is the
most basic superficial kind of
conservative commentary these days is
just
hey you see how crazy AOC is you could
do that you could fill a show with that
every single day and so I generally stay
away from it but sometimes
sometimes AOC
demonstrates such blight ignorance that
one cannot ignore it
and this occurred not just yesterday
talking about Washington DC not knowing
what the government of Washington DC is
supposed to be even according to the
Constitution but this happened a couple
days ago too when AOC was discussing the
big Tech
hearings and testimony when when the
Congress was grilling these big Tech
Executives especially on things like the
hunter Biden laptop story AOC went on a
tangent about how upset she is that Libs
of tick tock one of the great Twitter
accounts is still on Twitter despite
spreading false information
Miss navaroli are you familiar with the
account Libs of tick tock
I have heard of it from the news yes
um Mr Roth are you familiar with this
account
yes ma'am I am
are you aware from that from August 11th
to August 16th that account posted false
information about Boston Children's
Hospital claiming that they were
providing hysterectomies
to children
okay
the claim the accusation lives of tick
tock posted false information
suggesting that the Boston Children's
Hospital
transes the kids specifically provides
hysterectomies to children that's the
claim let's check to see if that
claim holds up Boston Children's
Hospital take it away
hysterectomy itself is the removal of
the uterus the cervix which is the
opening of the uterus and the Fallopian
tubes which are attached to the sides of
the uterus some gender affirming
hysterectomies will also include the
removal of the ovaries but that's
technically a separate procedure called
a bilateral oophorectomy and not every
gender forming hysterectomy includes
that and people who are getting gender
reforming hysterectomies do not have to
have their ovaries removed
so it sounds like Libs of tick tock was
right
because I'm watching a commercial now
from Boston Children's Hospital talking
about performing these hysterectomies I
I guess you could say that lives of tick
tock didn't go far enough
because Libs of tick tock should also
maybe have talked about bilateral
euphrectomies
is that how you pronounce that but
they did it AOC could have just Googled
that AOC launches into this this long
emotional rant about how Libs of tick
tock is lying about Boston Children's
Hospital and hysterectomy she could have
just Googled it it would have taken like
five words
she didn't do that
she could have saved herself the rant
about Washington DC by reading the
Constitution even just one time or
Having learned anything in civics class
in elementary school and I know that
they were teaching Civics back when AOC
was in school in Westchester because I
grew up one town away from AOC and AOC
went to the schools in the ritzier
wealthier nicer area so you you assumed
she had a civics class she just didn't
learn very much from it and it's not
just AOC I don't just mean to pick on
AOC there is a congressman
representative Dan Goldman he has a much
more impressive prestigious academic
pedigree certainly than AOC does and he
was humiliated almost as much frankly
even perhaps more than AOC because the
expectations for this man were higher
when discussing a basic aspect of free
speech law with the legal scholar
Jonathan Turley
does the First Amendment protect someone
from yelling fire in a movie theater
well unfortunately that one is not yes
or no because that's become a mantra for
people it's the homes uh shank line
Holmes himself walk back on all right
homes and we don't need a law class here
um so but you do agree though don't you
that the First Amendment does not
protect all speech
no there are limits to speech all
constitutional rights have limits
I felt as though I were watching Always
Sunny in this exchange so he says at the
top can you yell fire in a crowded
theater to suggest that the right to
free speech is not absolute which is
true but the the of course it's not
absolute as Jonathan truly admits but
that phrase yelling fire in a credit
theater that comes from a very famous
case shank versus the United States it
was a case about whether or not a man
could be thrown in jail for passing out
uh Flyers against the draft and against
the war and it's a complicated case I
write about it at length in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds number one National bestseller Run
free speech and the evolution of speech
but it's a complicated case and so
Jonathan Turley says well actually uh
representative Goldman you've picked
probably the worst example to talk about
this and because it's a little
complicated and it goes back to what
Oliver Wendell home said and what is the
representative hey hey all right here
listen we don't need to hear about
listen we don't it was just the Charlie
Day response
I know a lot about the law and various
other lawyerings um I'm well educated
well versed I know that situation is
like this real estate wise they're very
complex actually they're pretty simple
the forms are all standard boilerplate
okay well we're all hungry we're gonna
get to our hot plate soon enough all
right but let's talk about the contract
here sorry I forgot where did you go to
law school again uh well I could ask you
that very soon I went to Harvard how
about you where yeah I'm pleading the
fifth sir I'd advise that you do that
and I'll take that advice into
cooperation all right now let's say you
and I go toe-to-toe and bird law and see
who comes out to Victory you know I
don't think I'm gonna do anything
um close to that and I can see clearly
you know nothing about the law it seems
like you have a tenuous grasp on the
English language in general okay well
filibuster
yeah
do you do you know what that word means
yeah what's that mean
uh listen Professor can you do you do
you think you can yell fire in a crowded
theater
well actually
um the case that used that example ended
up being largely overdue okay okay
listen here Mister we don't need any of
your lawyerings okay uh let's go
toe-to-toe on bird law that's what
representative Dan Goldman sounds like
and what's so embarrassing about this is
that the joke in Always Sunny is that
Charlie day is completely uneducated
representative Dan Goldman went to
Stanford law
Dan Goldman went to what is considered
the second best most prestigious Law
School in the country
and he he doesn't even understand the
context
of one of the most basic slogans from
one of the most basic cases of free
speech these people
don't know anything and it's not just
AOC it's very easy to make fun of AOC
because she's infamously ignorant it's
all these guys it's not just AOC people
make fun of her they say oh she's a
bartender I know plenty of bartenders
who are a lot smarter and wiser than
graduates of Stanford law school okay
what's the excuse of the people from
Stanford Law School
[Music]
foreign